andré lucrèce vous êtes sociologue est
également écrivain est aussi rédacteur
en chef des cahiers du patrimoine qui
vont sortir donc officiellement le 5
août
ils seront disponibles d'abord au musée
de l'ethno l'histoire de l'ethnographie
je me trompe pas c'est ça qui est à fort
de france ensuite plus tard en livrer
alors par rapport à cette sortie donc
dans le contexte actuel on comprend
évidemment la logique qui vous a poussé
à parler des catastrophes naturelles
mais alors pourquoi avoir décidé de
parler de toutes les catastrophes
naturelles et humaines qui ont eu lieu
alors d'abord parce que les cahiers du
patrimoine et c'est de finalement de
rendre compte justement de nos
expériences patrimoniales et au fond les
catastrophes nous oblige finalement
avoir ces expériences là alors il est
doublement comme vous l'avez dit il est
doublement d'actualité d'abord parce que
son titre ces cyclones et on est en
période cyclonique épidémie est alors
que là en fait c'est le coronavirus qui
nous a poussés donc en quelque sorte à
réfléchir sur les épidémies passé et
puis bien entendu on est tendu ça aux
catastrophes naturelles et humaines pour
parler cette catastrophe qui est
historiquement la plus remarquable c'est
à dire des options de la montagne pelée
ta disparition d'une ville comme saint
pierre et surtout de ses habitants et
donc pour toutes ces raisons là on s'est
dit voilà parce qu'en fait il faut le
dire les cailloux du patrimoine sortent
pas deux fois par an et donc en fait
elle saute en juin et en décembre
juin c'est la période cyclonique et puis
comme je disais donc vient s'ajouter
donc cet autre catastrophe qu'est locaux
n'avaient évidemment alors vous
commencer par parler des kali'na go est
ce que rapidement vous pouvez nous
expliquer qu'ils sont qu'ils ont été et
pourquoi est-ce que vous commencez par
parler de leur vision a eu des aléas
naturels
parce que la trajectoire des cahiers du
patrimoine est toujours historique
tu as dû nous partons tous
des amérindiens et en fait ce sont des
gens qui ont subi pratiquement tout ce
que nous décrivons dans ce dans ce
numéro des cahiers du patrimoine les six
comme c'étaient des gens qui subissaient
les cyclones alors ça pour les éruptions
de volcans apparemment et vous savez ça
j'ai cru voir qu'ils étaient pas n'était
pas sûr dans leur vocabulaire qu'ils
avaient vraiment vécu les éruptions
volcaniques a fait tout à fait parce que
les ruptures évidemment il est tellement
rare que donc ils n'ont pas subi ça
alors que les cyclones évidemment sont
pratiquement chaque année nous menaçant
tout cas et puis bien sûr il y avait les
épidémies il faut savoir que les
amérindiens ont beaucoup souffert
d'épidémie en particulier d'épidémie de
la variole
parce que c'est pas une épidémie donc je
vous envie de dire autochtone 1 c'est
une épidémie qui a été amenée évidemment
par les européens lors de la conquête et
donc posséder sont là ils ont monté un
très lourd tribut en martinique en
guadeloupe mais pas seulement un
pratiquement dans toute la caraïbe et
donc ils ont hué par rapport à ça une
expérience aussi bien non que concernant
l'épidémie que concernant toutes les
catastrophes naturelles sauf évidemment
donc l'éruption d'accord merci thierry
l'étang dans l'éditorial dit que pour
lui les les cahiers du patrimoine
voudrait pour ce numéro lac donc le 34e
voudrait interroger nos actuels capacité
de résilience de résistance est ce que
vous pouvez expliquer ça oui tout à fait
alors écoutez je vais d'abord de quoi
critique par rapport au ca certaines
thèses qui disent par exemple que ce que
nous avons subi
évidemment qui est absolument atroce
c'est à dire la période esclavagiste
aurait laissé en quelque sorte de notre
adn donc qu'une une trace indélébile 1
et nous sommes enfin en tout cas moi je
suis tout à fait opposé à cette thèse là
en revanche ce que nous montre
précisément ce cahier là c'est que nous
avons beaucoup subi à la fois en
épidémie et en même temps en catastrophe
naturelle
et de ce point de vue ce qui est
remarquable c'est que nous nous très
rapidement nous nous remettons debout
vous donner des exemples cités dans le
dans le cahier vous avez en 1839 un
tremblement de terre qui ravage est
carrément à la fois la ville de saint
pierre mais surtout fort de france paie
et on décide à ce moment là de ne plus
construire non comme on construisait
auparavant et d'utiliser le bois
figurez vous que c'est quand en plus
tard et ce qui arrive
aimer c'est le grand incendie de fort de
france un incendie tellement
gigantesques que 70% donc de la ville de
fort de france et des tweets et et en
plus ça aurait été pratiquement 100% si
on n'avait pas décidé un moment donné ne
fait exploser le certain nombre de
maisons de telle sorte que le feu ne
couve pas l'ensemble de la ville
vous voyez on a subi des choses et tout
de suite après garcia oui mais encore
et bien cyclone quelques années après
donc je crois même d'ailleurs 91 1891 et
a lieu juste après précisément naissant
dit fort de france et en 1903 rebelote
cyclone donc au fond nous avons subi
toute une série de catastrophes et je
peux vous assurer que très rapidement la
martinique ces messieurs au pied et que
la population a fait face finalement
c'était vraiment pour montrer que oui
nous arrive beaucoup de choses qui
peuvent paraître début dramatique dur à
vivre mais qu'à chaque fois on a su se
relever ses équipes
d'où le terme de résistance ou wiki
qui sont en réalité dramatique quand on
prend ce qui s'est passé à saint pierre
c'est un drame absolu mais nous sommes
de ce point de vue réactif tout de suite
la martinique par exemple prenons
l'éruption de la montagne pelée
vous vous rendez-compte saint pierre
était une ville absolument
extraordinaire une ville de culture une
ville d'agriculture une ville de
commerce le port de saint-pierre owni
valises et avec la havane avec les
grands ports de la caraïbe et donc la
catastrophe
finalement balaie tout ça et 30000
personnes quasiment la population de
saint pierre disparaît et tout de suite
après six ans après on peut faire un
carnaval on le fait à fort de france
quelques années après on a un lycée qui
se dresse alors que le lycée schoelcher
de saint-pierre parce que celui-ci
cherchait à dabo était à saint pierre a
été bien entendu balayé par par
l'éruption mais pour vous disant que si
on devait comparer à aujourd'hui avec la
pub dans laquelle on est
quel événement est le plus significatif
dans tout ce que vous évoquez dans cette
édition
je pense que ce que nous subissons
aujourd'hui c'est ce sont surtout les
cyclones pourquoi parce que les autres
sont plus rares les tremblements de
terre on le connaît mais finalement ils
n'entame pas si vous voulez par exemple
la population la létalité de la
population ou autre chose et donc le et
là encore concernant les cyclones nous
faisons face où on a subi plusieurs
cyclones
alors évidemment vous avez des paysans
par exemple avec la banane qui paient le
prix le prix fort mais ça n'empêche pas
l'année suivante qui se remettent debout
et qui qu'il travaille à nouveau et ça
c'est ça justement la résistance et la
résidence donc aujourd'hui nous sommes
face à un grand cyclone et et c'est ça
quand vous comparez le coc u19 c'est sa
femme sur l'occident a analysé une
période qui pourrait y ressembler ce
serait ça parfait et concerne en
particulier d'épidémie d'accord je
remercie donc les cas du patrimoine qui
seront donc
disponible à partir du 5 août et je vous
remercie